hi everyone sal khan here welcome to the
homeroom live stream we have a very
exciting guest today anna agarwal
founder and ceo of edx and sorry i'm
messing with my video settings probably
at the exact wrong moment
but before i get into that i will give
everyone my standard announcements a
reminder that khan academy is a
not-for-profit organization we can only
exist through philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
making a donation at khan academy.org
donate
also want to make sure uh to give a
shout out to a whole series of
organizations that stepped up when they
realized that the world needed khan
academy more than ever during the
pandemic but also to support the world
we needed more resources our server
costs went up we were trying to
accelerate a whole series of content so
special thanks to bank for america at t
google.org novartis fastly in general
motors for really stepping up during the
pandemic and beyond the pandemic and to
all of our supporters corporate
philanthropic all of the above over the
years to really put us in a position so
that we can support as many of y'all
learners as as we can and last but not
least i want to remind everyone that
there's a version of this of this live
stream in podcast form wherever you get
your podcasts homeroom with sal the
podcast
so so check that out wherever you get
your podcast now with that i'm very
excited to introduce our guest today for
many many different reasons ananth
agarwal is the ceo and really the
founder of edx
he's a a co-member of the yudhan uh
council of luminaries he is a winner of
the non-prize in education
but maybe what most people don't realize
is that you were my professor in college
you were my recitation instructor i
believe it was in either it was either
in circuits or signals and systems you
might remember better
um you know i think it was in uh
circuit center electronics you know as
they say this is the one case
where i think the professor has learned
a lot more from a student than the other
way around
oh i know so much about circuits
professor
okay okay all right i'm gonna ask you my
first question i don't i i mean in all
fairness my degree is computer science
and electrical engineering it's much
more computer science and my wife rolls
her eyes um because
you one would assume with an electrical
engineering degree um i i would be able
to be more handy around the house but i
explain i'm very theoretical
and i'm afraid of electrocuting myself
or others
so i go i i turn to i turn to
professional but but give me give me
some software and i could definitely
go to town with that um i i before we go
into what you do now uh i mean what
i'm sure you remembered me when i was
your student you know in the sea of of
bright faces you're like that kid
yeah
i i had you begged when i saw the face i
said this person is going to be one of
the world's greatest luminaries in terms
of teaching and learning i i had you
pegged and you know when you went off
into the financial systems and so on
that was a total surprise but what
you're doing now you know i had you pick
buddy
[Laughter]
well i i will
i will take that for what for for for
what it's worth i'm i'm pretty much sure
that you don't remember me and i was
just a face in the crowd but
let's go into
what you now do so for for anyone who's
been living under a rock for the past 10
or so years
what is edx
edx is a
learning platform
where
we connect
some of the teachers and professors from
the greatest institutions in the world
like
mit and harvard stanford berkeley oxford
and others do learners from all over the
world so it's a platform where
learners who want to learn can come in
and learn from some of the best
professors and
teachers around the world and also from
companies like amazon web services
google ibm and others we have
about 40 million
learners on our platform where learners
come in and they can learn anything from
the humanities to computer science to
data science business
uh you can even learn
how to use mechanical ventilators a
course that we launched with harvard and
mgh
during covet times
about a year ago
and people can also own credentials
we have
these modular credentials like
micromasters and micro bachelors
that people can use to upskill
in their current job or if you've been
furloughed you can use that to gain new
skills for the future so this is who had
x's and you can come in then you can
start
learning uh you can learn for free on
the platform
and and absolutely
how did all of this come come to be what
you know you were a professor a very
successful professor at mit you had your
tenure you were running departments
you kind of gave that up to do this what
was the evolution of of going from
professor to edx and making this your
life
you know you know sad you had something
to do with it um
i would trace it back to uh
you know trace it back to uh uh
you know so for me education has always
been something near and dear to my heart
i remember
as a physics student at iit madras in my
first year i was one of two students out
of 300 that failed the first physics
exam and my you know part completely
stopped
and you know at that time i realized
that everybody around me seemed to
understand calculus based physics there
was no khan academy then remember
and i was here
i hadn't learned calculus-based physics
and had no idea what they were talking
about
and so up you know i said look you know
hopefully there'll be one day when
everybody will have equal access to
education and come up to speed as
everybody else
i really got a chance uh in in the year
2000 when mit launched opencourseware i
was one of the early professors to
launch my circuits course on
opencourseware and then you know sal
i've heard you talk about how you were
inspired by open courseware and you
launched a khan academy
and
you know i heard about your videos from
my children and others
and
you know
at mit a number of us were thinking
about what should the future look like
we did open courseware what would the
next big thing look like and then as a
confluence of multiple technologies
happened around 2008 2009 like social
networking
video distribution at scale cloud
computing
mobile computing
you know at that time
uh it was very clear that we could do
learning at scale and i launched a
program called websim
as part of you know our lab where i said
if i could teach people how to do
circuits labs fully online then maybe
this is something we could do at scale
and so on the average day two to three
hundred students from all over the world
would come in and do web sim which is
think of it as a mooc lab and this was i
built it out in 2003 and this was being
massively open
but before a good mapping online
questions existed
oh it just was you know nine years
before they existed 2003 now you could
maybe call it the mool massive open
online labs it was circuits labs and i
figured if i could do online circuits
labs then maybe i could do uh
you know other things but then i did
nothing beyond that i just kept running
the web sim and then
inspired by you sal in 2011 a number of
us at mit got together uh the leadership
at mit raphael rife myself leadership
harvard alan carver and others began
thinking about how could we take this to
the next level and that's how edx was
born when we said look rather than just
having course materials as an open
course where why don't we take complete
courses
with certificates with communities and
also with labs and real hands-on
experiences and make that available to
the world and that's when we launched
mitx in december of 2011 and turned into
edx when we partnered uh you know with
harvard and mit uh in early may and
launched edx that's how it all came
together
and and what made you try to make this
your life journey you know as i said you
had a you had a good gig as a professor
head of departments
you know what it's one of those things
where uh
uh you know i'm uh as far as life is
concerned
uh i'm a uh i'm very much an
incrementalist uh i don't plan very far
out and uh you know i sort of take it uh
one base at a time you know to use a
baseball uh analogy
and so
uh when the opportunity arose uh
we decided uh we'd create a mooc
platform
and initially called mitx and then
called edx
i was the head of the computer science
and ai lab at mit and uh you know had a
25 strong research group with phd
students and postdocs and undergrads and
so on
and so we incubated what would become
edx in the basement of csail the
computer science and ai lab at mit
and uh i was looking to recruit
professors to teach the first course on
edx
and when i told people yeah the course
needs to start in two months and oh by
the way we are building a completely new
platform we wanted an open source
platform that uses python and django and
the latest technologies and not the old
stuff cloud-based there's nothing
nothing available at that time and so
professor my colleagues said your nuts
can do it
and so uh you know by that time we'd
announced edx there's no one ready to
teach something and so uh you know we
denounced it and so i jumped in and said
you know look up the launch with the
circuits course and people looked up
uh to me as if i was crazy why would you
launch with a circuit scores as opposed
to something like machine learning or
python programming i said look that's
the best we can do i could not get
my colleagues to do this quickly enough
they felt we were nuts and so that's how
we launched with the circuits course and
i kind of got sucked into it
having to uh you know having to do it uh
do the first course myself with several
of my colleagues like jerry sussman uh
jacob white chris turman and others who
really jumped in and pitched in to make
it happen
you know it's it's it's it's a it's a
great story and i i do want to ask
where this is all going where do you see
the future but
i'm getting an unusual number of
questions coming in through the message
board so i want to make sure i get to
some of these uh this is just kind of a
fun question from youtube
antonine epolius what's your favorite
thing in math maybe i'll i'll expand
antonine's question a little bit what's
your favorite thing in all of knowledge
in all of learning
you know
i'll answer both questions my favorite
thing in math actually was
when i really
one day i kind of just got it i really
figured out
how to solve differential equations
which is that
you try not to overthink it you just
kind of do it mechanically and you and
you apply templates and do it
and uh and actually i remember in my
circuits course we used first and
second-order differential equations and
solutions of those
and i actually called up
my my student who had this little gig
going in uh
in california and i called him up and
said hey look you know i need uh your
website doesn't have a video tutorial on
uh you know first order differential
equations uh so i need you to create
something for me and this guy did it and
his name was khan academy so in my
course on edx i have a tutorial from sal
khan
uh you know on some of the stuff
but
in terms of
in all of learning i think the thing uh
you know my dream is one day to really
understand quantum mechanics um i i
don't i don't understand it i've never
really gotten it deeply i can do the
math and do some of the formal lake
stuff but my dream one day is to really
have the time to sit down and listen to
fineman's lectures and and others and
really really truly truly rock it
you know i'm not there yet
you know it's interesting
my
quantum mechanics and sorry are you
getting a little buzz every time i talk
every time i start to talk it sounds
like there's a little uh did you hear
that no no i'm okay i'm good good good
good no would you mention quantum
mechanics that is one of those things
that i i also want
i seek to have a deeper understanding of
it but i think anyone the first time you
learn it and you say wow a
all matter has both particle and
wave-like properties that
the electron is a wave until you attempt
to observe it and then it collapses the
wave function collapses and then you
know its position like it's so
counterintuitive to
what we think is our understanding or
our perception of the universe and
actually i probably had
the the most interesting insight that
affects my my understanding of quantum
mechanics when i was reading this um
this question and answer this is
recently this is with a uh uh an indian
guru who died in the 1980s his name is
srina sargadatta maharaj and he wrote
this actually he didn't write this book
this book i am that is based on
conversations with him and and you know
he he's apparently you know had reached
nirvana or muksha or you know had kind
of reached enlightenment and people are
always asking him these questions and
they keep asking them well what is the
cause of this and what is the cause of
that and he he says you are so obsessed
with causality
what you call causality is just repeated
correlation
uh yeah and and i was like is he right
is it just repeated correlation and i'm
still processing that but that actually
in some ways opened my mind to things
like quantum mechanics
would seem to defy our standard our
standard intuitions whatever the
intuition is of causality and and and
correlation but yeah i think that's
that's right absolutely i you know
i did have a really really deep
understanding of uh
you know newtonian mechanics and so on
and maybe that was part of the problem i
really deeply got it
and then when you have to completely
rethink things and and
change your frame of reference it almost
became like one of the yogi yogi better
quotes you know wherever you go there
you are you said yeah i understand that
but when you really think about it
deeply you say no i don't got that i
have no idea what that means and then
the deeper i began thinking about
you know quantum mechanics and things
like that the more i realized that well
i could do the math and do calculations
the speed of light and you know the
compression you know time and all of
that stuff and space i could do the math
but i never really really internalized
and got it so my dream one day is to
really really get it
yeah
completely agree and and it's yeah it's
it's a um
i mean i i could go on into this but
like you know how much is is based on
perception well anyway we we could we
could go
more into this another fun quote from
from that from that guru was when
someone you know he's like you know you
you you ascribe reality to certain
things and you ascribe imagination or
dream like to other things but imagine
if your dreams picked off where they
left off the night before then all of a
sudden you would have two realities
anyway
we're going way up but quantum mechanics
makes me think of that i i think it i
think it goes much better with the beard
in your hand actually
[Laughter]
we're not a lot of kids are watching
professor agarwal
that's cool you're a role model be
careful what you advocate for
so
more questions and really good ones uh
several from badri ratnam on youtube
so one of the questions is dr agarwal
india in the third world was hit hard by
kovid in one of your talks you had
mentioned that there's a plan to put the
entire medical education curriculum
online how is that progressing
um i i did give a give a talk where we
are talking to a number of universities
where
where the idea is you know could we put
an entire medical
curriculum online and i know the same
applies to computer science uh data
science business
and we've been sort of going at it one
at a time uh we made huge inroads into
computer science data science and
business
on edx we have over 3000 courses and
we're making great inroads in these
areas
i would say healthcare is going to be
next
where we do have a fair number of
courses at this time
but
the idea would be imagine if
you could learn about you know topics
like biochemistry biology you know
epidemiology you know pathology a lot of
a lot of the theoretical aspects of
these subjects but then you go to
college and you learn and you practice
and you know you you have you work with
real categories and all of that stuff
and you really really practice and uh
look at patients and and work with
patients and sick people uh that would
be the way to do it sort of blended
model of learning where what you could
learn online you sort of learn online
and then
you do all the practicum stuff when you
come to a physical
medical space and so to me that would be
something that is very exciting and uh
and something that we would be
interested in doing in the future but
again you know we started with computer
science data science and business where
we've really built out a pretty deep
curricula in those areas
yeah it seems
you and i have definitely
talked talked about this in the past
that the potential for i mean medicine
is a big one considering the shortage of
healthcare workers around the world uh
but there's so many fields that i think
you know between the edx's of the world
and the khan academy's world i think
we're actually just at the at the very
early early stages i have another
question here and this is really i
you're clearly an educator reaching
millions so there's that hat but there's
also you used to be the head of the ai
lab
at mit so you know the thing or two i'm
assuming about that uh you know from
youtube saurav saha asks what are your
thoughts about the future of automation
in different fields of technology and
then i'll add to the question is you
know
so and given your views of where
automation and machine learning and
robotics are going
where do you see education needing to go
or maybe even leveraging some of those
trends
oh my god there's so much we could talk
about here um
certainly uh
the computer science and ai lab at mit
is one of the centers for
ai machine learning research you know a
number of other universities and
and companies are also where incredible
research is happening in ai and machine
learning
and you know much as computing and the
internet changed the world in the late
80s
uh machine learning and ai and
automation are completely transforming
industry
uh today and in the future uh
the downside is that people talk about
roughly 50 of today's jobs will be
transformed into other jobs that will
require new sets of skills where a whole
planet half the planet of people need to
be upskilling and reskilling and that's
one of the areas that edx focuses in
very heavily
then we offer
professional certificates and
micromasters and micro bachelors and
other credentials
in these topic areas where people can
come in and re-skill with short courses
and programs and things like machine
learning and ai but certainly we're
seeing transformations of industries
where
in the past i'll just give you a simple
example
let's say for example
a translation um you know when you speak
uh you know uh
usually humans would translate what you
said into some other language at the u.n
and so on you've seen some of these
you've probably seen the movie
interpreter uh where you know nicole
kidman was out there you know
translating in real time what people
were saying now imagine but today that
this technology is is there where even
as you speak a machine could be
translating you into one of any number
of languages and you know machine
learning technology is key to uh key to
things like this
uh to your second question sal
i think i think the same thing huge
impact will happen in the learning field
as well
where first of all let me start by
saying the teacher is always going to be
critical um i think people need to
connect with people and get inspired and
you know they're looking for mentors and
so on and you know i too had some
incredible mentors
in my school and uh and college
i'm hoping we can talk about some of
them but at the same time machine
learning and ai can take over many of
the tasks so for example i'll give you
one example one of the things we worked
on at edx
was a shifting framework but imagine
based on
the solutions that people were
developing for problems imagine that you
could create a hinting framework where
if a student got stuck in a problem
they'd say okay give me a hint and the
computer gives them a hint based on all
the solutions they've seen in the past
and so
there are so many things you could do
another example is some amazing work
that berkeley did where
they did research using edx learner data
where looking at the progression of
learner activity they could tell when a
learner was going to drop out of a
course and so using machine learning and
then based on that you could actually
create interventions and mentorships
that happen just at the right time to
enable someone to get more motivated and
to stay in the course and these are just
two examples uh georgia tech has done
and ibm have done research in some edx
courses where
the teaching assistants in the
discussion forums uh the live teaching
assistants have been
experimenting in some cases replaced by
ai technology where some of the
questions were answered
again using machine learning as a basis
for building up the uh
you know the repertoire of questions on
which to train the machine learning
model so i can see many many areas where
learning and teachers and universities
and schools can benefit usually from ai
and machine learning you know helping
learners uh you know do a lot better
imagine to me one of the big ones is
personalized learning where imagine if
every learner could have a personalized
tutor that could teach them uh you know
problems in certain areas
at their own pace in a way that was
completely customized to them to me
that's one of the big holy grails of of
of teaching and learning
no i i couldn't agree with
these notions of personalization
but but i i am curious you know how do
you think this is going to affect and i
agree with you also that this will never
replace the teacher that human
connection actually is probably going to
become even more important over time as
other things get automated but what do
you think this is going to do to labor
markets are there going to be you know
there's kind of these techno optimists
to say well the industrial revolution
yes a lot of jobs were lost but a lot of
jobs got created do you think that's
just going to be the same thing we just
have to have some optimistic faith that
will happen or do we think this time is
different because of the nature of the
tasks that machine learning and robotics
can can take on and and if so
yeah how do we get the positives while
mitigating the negatives
i think we're seeing some of this happen
today where
where jobs get transformed into uh
into new jobs
where you know just imagine that
let's say for example uh you're driving
a truck
and uh you know autonomous vehicles
self-driving cars are
uh you know almost there i think there's
still some tweaking that needs to be
done but they're almost there and so one
could imagine that you'll think oh my
goodness you know
we'll never have people driving cars
anymore and for trucks that rumble from
the west coast to the east coast or
wherever in the world
you won't have drivers but just imagine
uh those would be you'd need other
skills you need people that maybe you
need a i don't know maybe an i.t
technician or an i.t expert you know uh
in in the truck uh making sure that uh
you know all the i.t and support systems
are working well making sure that there
are fail-safe models and making sure
that when you come to areas
where
uh the ai your machine learning doesn't
quite cut it you know i can imagine
uh you know if you're trying to i've
tried to drive a a vespa a scooter on
the small streets of maratha then near
delhi in india and i promise you i
promise you uh you know i don't think
that
you can have any machine learning
technology do a self-driving car or
something on the streets of moradabad
where you know any random molecule or a
particle or biological entity is coming
from every which direction it's it's
it's insane
and so so i think you'll need people for
that and but i think you'll need more
people who are generalists that can do
driving as well as some other stuff so i
do see that jobs will transform into
newer jobs which is why this whole
concept of upskilling and reskilling is
so important in marketing you know a lot
of the kind of marketing we did earlier
has now transformed to digital marketing
analytics has taken off and so today
uh you know data science teams of
companies have grown uh they do machine
learning data science you know
statistics and so on and those teams are
becoming bigger so even as certain kinds
of teams are diminishing
you see the burgeoning of i.t teams you
see burgeoning of data science teams and
i think the same kind of trend will keep
will keep happening we look at computing
when data centers went away to the cloud
people said oh my god you know
uh you know so many jobs will be lost
but guess what there's more jobs in
computer science more jobs in data
centers you know we need the ops people
we need up support people that
understand how to do load balancing and
security and privacy and all of that
stuff so really jobs get transformed and
you know you need new kinds of skills or
adjacent skills that people have to uh
to really become expert on
it's interesting one of the examples
that was given to me recently which made
a lot of sense was you know something
like online commerce we imagine i mean
it has in some ways disrupted a lot of
place-based retail but it didn't remove
although maybe machine learning and
robotics might change some of it but
still someone is
picking things putting them in a basket
and actually it has created the new job
of bringing it that last mile to
someone's door which wasn't there before
because no one had the expectation that
they would be able to click a few things
on an app and then their groceries show
up at their door or you know the book
they want to buy shows up there at the
door you know within within within 24
hours but it is going to be interesting
i i i hope that we create more jobs and
actually the jobs are even higher value
but there's this there is this notion of
technology is hyper productive which
means that you can get the same output
with less with less labor so uh
you know but but my gut sense is we edx
and khan academy we got a role to play
to make sure that
most of the jobs are going to be higher
up the value chain more kind of
knowledge economy jobs and so
we need to make sure more people are
prepared to be there uh in in this world
we're going to
i think what's interesting here sal is
that
i actually see this maybe it goes back
to quantum mechanics you know i see sort
of a cyclic thing happening here where
as we think we are climbing up the
ladder and learning the newer and higher
tech skills
what we're also seeing within
enterprises is that
more and more employees and companies
are doubling down on kind of you know
what they call soft skills uh really
it's better to call them power skills or
human skills where
empathy and teamwork and collaboration
creativity you know design thinking
empathy these are all becoming a lot
more important where machines don't
quite do that and so i think we will see
kind of going kind of back to the future
approach where
or maybe more like you know
future to the past or whatever where the
human skills will be emphasized where
whether in companies or in teaching and
so on
the human skills will be emphasized
where people can do what they're good at
which is being human
i i couldn't i couldn't agree more i
think i think there's something about
technology and as we get some of our
material needs met by more and more
productive technology we realize that
some of these core ideas that we've had
for hundreds of thousands years of human
history the community being part of a
village being part of a clan being part
of a tribe
that we've gone through a first phase of
technology kind of separating us and and
we see it anxiety
depression loneliness are really
epidemics and disproportionately
epidemic it seems in the western more
materially successful world
and i hope you're right that as we as
more things get automated we start
realizing hey that frees us up to kind
of be the humans in the village and
connect with each other and emotionally
people talk about healthcare
you know there's probably gonna be a lot
of jobs and just make sure people have
companionship make sure you know there's
a lot of studies that the best doctors
who cares what the medicine they're
giving is are they are does the patient
feel like they're being heard do they
feel like they're being cared for so uh
and and this goes this does go back to
the quantum physics and sri na sargada
maharaja around uh perception is often
reality and this feeling of
connectedness a feeling is a real thing
that we can't understand exactly
well this got way more philosophical
than i had expected i thought we were
just going to talk about democratizing
education which is a big idea in of
itself but you know you have a lot of
folks young people people of all ages
you know i mean i'll let you take us
home uh honest uh what where where is
all this going where do you hope this
goes what advice should what what should
be people's takeaways
you know i think it's very simple uh you
know khan academy edx and so on
have been doing online learning you know
you've been doing it for oh my god 15
years
we've been doing it at edx for about 10
years
um and we began doing this well before
the pandemic
but then the pandemic hit about a year
ago and the whole world went to online
learning and online working remote work
i think i think this is here to stay i
think the one message i have for
everybody is that the future is going to
be blended where whether you're in
school or college
uh there's going to be a combination of
online learning and in personal learning
where people figure out what are the
best things to do online what are the
best things to do in person so for
example lectures
isn't it better to sit in front of a you
know watch short videos and i call them
khan style videos 5 10 minute videos
that you can pause rewind as many times
as you want and you can do it at
midnight isn't that so much better than
going to a lecture for
60 minutes or worse 90 minutes at 8
o'clock in the morning and those things
are better done online however certain
other things like maybe collaborating
with a couple of uh
dorm mates on a on a problem set or
building something uh or
working one-on-one with a professor
some of these things might be better
than online i think we'll figure out the
blended model so to me my last message
is that
you know if when you're in school and
i would focus on making sure that you
learn how to learn not just in person
but also learn how to learn online and
we actually launched a couple of courses
on edx on how to learn online this would
be a very critical skill going ahead
because in the future all learning will
be a combination of online and in-person
learning
i love it i couldn't agree more we
always have a good time uh chatting uh
ana professor agarwal uh thank you so
much for joining us and i'm i'm excited
to to go on this journey with you
because i think uh i i think it could it
could make a a big dent in the universe
well fantastic sal always great chatting
with you you've been an inspiration i
would not have been doing this uh uh had
it not been for uh for the work that you
did uh and so just keep up all that you
do and uh and and hope we continue to
collaborate and do great things in the
future
thank you so much
well thank you thanks everyone
for for joining uh as you could tell
very fun conversation and uh myself and
onyx go way way way back
probably before he remembers it but i i
he was i don't remember all my
professors but i definitely remember him
i had no idea that our our lives would
converge in in this way but you know
every few months we get together when
one of us is in when he's either in the
bay area or i'm in boston and uh you
know we end up spending hours chatting
about a million different things on a
million different dimensions so uh
really really interesting guy and edx i
think is doing some incredibly powerful
work and it really picks up where to
some degree khan academy leaves off uh
and and so i think between these types
of organizations and others there's a
real chance to to provide really rich
resources for learners and for educators
around the world uh but thank you so
much for joining uh thank you for being
fired i'm sorry for all of y'all i
couldn't get to all of your questions i
will try to be better about that next
time
but thanks for joining us on this on
this live stream
onward
you